[Musik]
ein großteil der fläche unbewohnbar
gemacht hat hat sich die menschheit in
eine hand voll super metropolen
zurückgezogen der permanente säure wegen
macht und seit fünf jahren die
ausgangssperren um fällig die von den
regierungen verhängt wurden um die
umwelt vor uns menschen zu schützen
die meisten von uns verbringen 95
prozent ihrer wachzeit in einer
virtuellen perfekte nachbildung der
realität von 2010 oder eher treiben sich
in einer von unzähligen frei erstellten
simulationen herum alle die zunächst sie
brillen abgelegt haben haben entweder
ihre meinung geändert oder sind durch
die isolation einfach verrückt geworden
so könnte deutschland realität in einem
sehr dunklen version der zukunft
verwendung finden aber egal wie sich wie
auswirken wird
wir stehen erst am anfang doch wie weit
sind die brillen aktuell noch von der
perfekten illusion entfernt kann mal ein
bewusstsein schon heute in einem
computer wohn und die welt ohne
physische grenzen und körper als sein
neues zuhause sehen werde ich nach
dieser woche grenzenlose macht in wir
jemals zurück in mein normales leben
finden oder überhaupt wollen ich
verdiene mein geld im internet ich
könnte da drin so lang sein wie ich
möchte auf jeden fall aber werde ich in
dieser einen woche hunderte leben leben
ich werde in die zukunft reisen und
meine füße auf planeten setzen die noch
nie zuvor ein mensch erkundet hat danach
in die vergangenheit reisen und
dinosaurier beobachten anschließend in
der gegenwart freundschaften schließen
und meine eigene welt erschaffen aber
bevor ich eine woche in der virtuellen
realität verschwinde ohne diese brille
auch nur ein einziges mal abzunehmen
muss ich erst mal herausfinden wie
dieses ding überhaupt funktioniert und
wie ich euch mitnehmen kann
dorthin wo ich hingehen dieses video
geht unterstützt von skill scheer
logbuch ein tag ein system kann gerade
an
ich probiere es kann also dann war alles
schwarz weiß und verpixelt aber 3d ist
das doch laut beantragt den überblick
ach da sind zwei der drauf logbuch 15
nach gut einer stunde tut ein bisschen
weh aber ansonsten tv documenta 7 kann
man freunde treffen das in 10 78 19
krank eintrag neue erstmal die armee
sowie
es ist immer sogar ein paar konnte jetzt
die fans die ein comeback das eintrag 13
ich kann das ding mittlerweile
problemlos 15 stunden tragen aber so ein
bisschen unbequem deswegen man jetzt die
polsterung hin gewann
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich mir zwei kabelbindern
diese bank ihr fest jetzt kann ich das
ding mehr oder weniger kabellos aufladen
oder viel besser ausbalanciert heißt
geht gar nicht mehr so genannten buch
ein tag 14 ich richte jetzt mein
greenscreen ein für die mixed werdet ihr
auch blog buch einfach 15
der grinst viel in school größer als
erwartet logbuch einfach sitzen ich
versuche jetzt zum ersten mal nicht in
minecraft rhein zu green screen so ich
bin jetzt in meinen kräften
ich bin drin blogeintrag 22 schreibt
sich die gäste couch das zimmer komplett
umgestellt damit ich jetzt meine ganzen
pc daten kann
[Musik]
glauburg ein tag 29 alle tests
abgeschlossen aixtron stadt ist geplant
für morgen
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ab sofort eine woche das
ist jetzt mein neues zuhause
was das ist mein neues zuhause check
hier das sofa in wenigen sekunden geht
zum beispiel das hier mein neues zuhause
hierbei ist auch wenn ich ja mal doppelt
tippe sehe ich die welt so und das ist
immer wieder das gefühl dass wir dort
auf die frage wie dieses externe möglich
ist ich sehe jetzt quasi alles was ich
mir in meinen augen auch ziehen würde
nur durch diese kamera ist diese woche
kann ich machen was ich will und sein wo
ich will
wie wäre es denn damit es leichter als
wird
das ist gut das ist trading in der
zukunft da ist eine verrückte woche das
sind so schönberger hinein selbst
schönste jemals gesehen habe bin laden
im planet mit minus 61 grad
was sind das sind wir dinge alters in
tokio töten
ja ok aber ob kompetent das ist heftig
ich mache mich auch in die weiten der
galaxie und je weiter ich ins universum
ab trifft desto weiter trifft sich auch
in die virtuelle realität
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nachdem ich weiß wer wie viele stunden
meinen körper die kamera essen und
trinken vergessen habe weckt mich mein
hunger irgendwann aus meinem abenteuern
obwohl es mindestens zu abenteuer reich
ist wie die reise durchs all sieht das
essen nvr gar nicht atemberaubend aus ok
jetzt ist es zeit zum schlafen
das geht erst mal auch zum zähneputzen
aber dank der außenkameras an meiner
brille ist es mir wenigstens möglich
diese grundlegendsten dinge trotz brille
überhaupt für eine woche durchzuziehen
und das ist ganz schön ermüdend lege ich
mir noch einmal hin da drüben stehen der
kamera mich extra so aufgestellt dass
sie mich jetzt schlafen nur um dem
moment aufgefangen in dem ich in virtual
reality aufwachen rät aber natürlich
auch ein bisschen um zu zeigen dass sich
die brille selbst dann trage während die
sonne beim schlafen hinter mir aufgeht
ich liebe es mir etwas selbst
beizubringen und probiere in meinen
videos jede woche etwas neues um meinen
horizont zu erweitern was geht da gibt
es tausende kurse zu allen interessen
wie zum beispiel produktivität
selbständigkeit oder fotografie und
viele mehr und das für profis und für
anfänger aktuell bringe ich mit dem kurs
projektteam aus dem chaos create a
custom system networks von thomas frank
meinen tagesablauf auf vordermann in der
klasse zeigt er wie man eine struktur in
seinen alltag bekommt und mit
verschiedenen kostenlosen tools sein
leben und seine arbeit effizient plant
nur viel zu schaffen und einen klaren
kopf dabei zu behalten die ersten 500
meiner abonnenten die auf den link in
dem video beschreibung klicken bekommen
zwei monate der premium-mitgliedschaft
skill hat keinen erste werbung bringt
ständig neue kassen heraus mit denen ihr
euch ein spannendes leben aufbauen
können und kostet in einem jährlichen
aber nur acht euro pro monat also schlag
zu guten morgen nach kurzer aber immer
gute dienste vielleicht weil ich bin
aufgewacht zur absolut komisches gefühl
in jahren aufzuwachen und ich bin
wirklich oft aufgebracht deswegen weil
jedes mal wieder sowohl formal ich bin
war mir auf gewalt an sich geht aber ich
bin über tritt hat guten schlag gekriegt
ich sagen jetzt geht es erst ein
bisschen an sport und mache zu werden
[Musik]
auch wenn die schläge nur halb so brutal
aussagen wie sie sich angefühlt haben es
war unfassbar anstrengend als ich nach
einer halben stunde mit diesem workout
fertig war
sportlich gesehen ist der tischtennis
tatsächlich ein gutes stück entspannter
ich spiele erst gegen eine ki und
verliere dann spiele ich gegen einen
echten spieler und da völlig natürlich
auch es ist extrem krass wie gut
emotionen allein durch die bewegungen
von händen und kopf in die virtuelle
realität übertragen werden und so freue
ich mich richtig wenn mein gegner obwohl
ich verloren habe freundlich winkt das
geht allerdings auch in die andere
richtung dann gegen diese spieler
verliere ich zugegebenermaßen haushoch
und auf jeden fall sieht man wir hier
extrem enttäuscht von mir ist und um
ehrlich zu sein hat mich das echt
richtig verletzt und das allein durch
die bewegung seines kopfes und seine
hände ich denke das zeigt ziemlich gut
dass vorher technik nicht perfekt sein
muss um schon extrem krass realistische
erfahrungen hervorzurufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay es gibt es was geiles diese pea
alsdorfer gemacht dann gedacht war
ich weiß nicht wie ich das anstellen
sollen mit dem steht kirchen hierher
ja also richtig anstrengend führen kopf
zu werden ist komplett belastend ist
dann doch irgendwie ist so unfassbar
guck mal das gefühl jetzt auch mal
schlafen
mittlerweile ist die brille echt ein
teil von mir geworden und deswegen fühlt
es sich extrem komisch an an den kabeln
rum zu forschen es fühlt sich an als
würde ich ein kabel aus meinem kopf raus
ziehen oder sie meinen kopf einstecken
diese kabel also ich fühle mich dort
wirklich mit ein bisschen aufgeladen
ich habe mich einigermaßen geduscht ohne
die brille dabei natürlich nachzumachen
und habe danach etwas schlagzeug
gespielt was tatsächlich auf
funktioniert den bio eine ahnung wann
aber irgendwann bin ich auch wieder ins
bett den ganzen sport gemacht oder
gezockt aber jetzt wird alles gearbeitet
weil nur weil ich jetzt in der
virtuellen realität bin heißt ja nicht
dass ich da nicht auch arbeiten kann und
nutzer wie mache ich das ich gehe hier
in virtual desktop rein und zwar kann
ich mir meinen händen diesen bildschirm
vergrößern werde jetzt mit meinem pc
connected kann auch dazu weg gehen ich
könnte so auch jetzt in andere zimmer
seien damit kann ich jetzt meinen pc
steuern und hier kann ich als video
skript ich kann mir den bildschirm auch
nach oben setzen und kann nicht so
zurücklehnen so sagt ich bin im weltall
finde ich tatsächlich im coolsten als
allererstes ich habe eine weile
gearbeitet aber ich muss in die alle
paar stunden schlafen um meine augen und
meinen kopf und generell meinen ganzen
verstand zu erholen ich bin drei stunden
war und schlafen wieder zwei stunden und
bin wieder zwei stunden war und das
zerstörten ein gefühl von zeit umso mehr
tag 4 ich kann es nicht glauben basiert
und dann so lange hier drin steckt
langsam gar keinen plan mehr als abbild
meine stirn tut auch sophia debatte
daran gestoppt
mein bewusstsein schwimmt einfach nur
noch durch diese ganze fenster und menüs
[Musik]
es wird sich mittlerweile an als würde
diese brille mit meiner haut
zusammenwachsen und es fühlt sich gut an
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall noch mit
die schwerelosigkeit düsen in kobe
die leute werden mich übrigens hier drin
wer kein deutsch das geht wie kann ich
erwarte hier und schon habe ich meinen
ersten freund in die ahl gefunden
[Musik]
da wird
gut
gar nicht
wunderschön
daun
bono
ich halte die ab oder auch nicht
[Musik]
ja also ich habe in dem game über die
zeit vergessen aber jetzt war ich kann
ich mir meine stirn zu übertrieben w o
mein gott sind einfach ich will gar
nicht wissen was darunter ist ich will
gar nicht wissen wie ich denke das ist
ein echt schwer aber ich glaube ich muss
das ganze abhängen
das sind normale schmerz nicht dass ich
kann sagen ich bin echt gespannt wie das
aussieht wenn ich jetzt wieder abnehmen
dass ich glaube dass das erste
experiment das ich abbrecher so aber tag
5 und 7 weiter komme ich nicht machen
sie mal da ich werde es mit so viel
rausgehen und das ding ab oh gott wie
fühlt sich die realität an nach fünf
tagen wieder stimuliert ich hab das
gefühl dass da in meinem kopf zusammen
es treten wir das zu lösen von meiner
haut all das ist hell holy moly wie
sieht meine stirn aus wird es gut kommt
wie fühlst du dich frei die nasa hat die
ganze nacht gedrückt sehe ich aus als
wenn ich gerade aus einer schlägerei
gekommen
komplett geräumt an der stelle in einem
kornfeld komplett aufgebraucht das
kleine bläschen ja ich spüre aber
einfach gar nix also es brennt hat hier
aus aber ja der stadt sprüchen nicht
einfach jemanden duschen weshalb kraß
wieder alles scharf zu sehen und auch so
flüssig unsere ohne verzögerung immer a
ha ha
ich habe also wieder zurück ins normale
leben gefunden und ich bin wirklich froh
an dieser stelle nochmal der hinweis
macht das auf gar keinen fall nach auch
wenn ich relativ gut weggesteckt habe
ist es absolut ungesund für die augen
seht euch dazu am besten mal das video
von markus angeschrien an und wird sich
meine stirn jemals wieder komplett
normalisiert das weiß ich nicht aber für
ein zwei stunden ist ja etwas
großartiges und ich freue mich schon
wenn ich in einigen tagen wieder
reingehen kann
links kelch er ist in der video
beschreibung ab heute ist übrigens auch
die kanal mitglied bei mir verfügbar
wenn er mich also auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte dann schaut mal davor
bei oder abonniert mich auf diesem kanal
und dann sehen wir zum nächsten mal
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]